hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive so it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the telegraph's assistant comment editor
olivia utley and the political editor of
huffpost uk kevin schofield so very good
to see you both good evening to you
so let's take a look then at what's
making the front pages and after the
bombing of a school and also a theater
where hundreds of people were sheltering
from attack the guardian says russia is
now being accused by several countries
including britain of committing war
crimes
while the eye reports that vladimir
putin may have to abandon his planned
tank assault on kiev because of the
strong resistance his forces are meeting
as the times puts it ukraine is taking
the fight to putin
the mirror focuses on the bravery of
mothers in ukraine who've braved the
russian shelling to rescue hundreds of
children from kiev
the daily telegraph says russian
impostors have been targeting two uk
cabinet ministers by posing as ukrainian
politicians in an effort to extract
sensitive or embarrassing information
the financial times leads with the
decision by piano ferries to halt
sailings and replace 800 workers with
cheaper labour as it tries to keep the
business viable amid annual losses of a
hundred million pounds
the metro describes how the company
faced mutiny from sacked workers and
even one captain who refused to leave
their vessels after the news
and mutiny is also how the daily mail
describes the actions of sacked workers
while the sun has this description of
piano management
which we'll leave for you to read
and just a reminder that by scanning the
qr code that you can see on screen
during the program you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers for
yourself while you watch us
so let's uh bring in olivia atlee and
kevin schofield to go through some of
those front pages and olivia let's talk
about ukraine first of all shall we
because the papers seem to be split
between
front pages devoted to ukraine and those
devoted to pno so we'll try and talk a
little bit about both if we can at the
eye first of all we've had a lot in the
last few days about the russian advanced
stalling the eye suggesting that there
are some intelligence officials that
believe that now putin won't move the
tanks into the capital
yes the idea is that there's been so
much resistance in kiev so far
that there probably isn't much point in
russia trying to send troops on the
ground into keefe that sounds like it's
good news uh what the eye then goes on
to explain is that it probably isn't
such good news because what it looks
like russia will choose to do instead is
to increase its shelling on keeve um and
just try to obliterate the city like
that rather than send sending troops on
the ground
so it's not as positive as it might
might appear at face value well that's
right yes the headline does look does
look optimistic but as you say it isn't
let's move on to the guardian shall we
kevin because we talk about the risk of
increased bombardment there are parts of
the country already suffering heavy
shelling not least mario poll
where we've seen the shelling of a
theater where people were sheltering
now more and more countries
expressing their view that that makes
russia war criminals
yeah i think it's fairly significant um
president biden obviously
said uh these were war crimes uh
yesterday and that caused quite a lot of
consolation in moscow boris johnson did
it a couple of weeks ago so our
ministers have been saying for quite
some time now and obviously we assist in
a national criminal court trying to
build a case uh against uh russia and
against vladimir putin and this is
simply further evidence and the the
theater i mean the details of it are
absolutely horrific there was um it was
written on the ground outside the
theater children so that um the fighter
pilots above knew very well that these
were young youngsters uh hiding
in this building and they still bombed
it um absolutely horrific and as i say
yeah this just adds to the
the huge weight of evidence that is
building up and it's pretty
incontrovertible now i think that the
war crimes are actually
are taking place
okay and let's take in the telegraphs
coverage of ukraine um olivia your paper
russians target patel and wallace with
fake video calls and this th the this
these scam calls have been um revealed
by ben wallace himself haven't haven't
they how how worrying is this are they
is it just embarrassing or could
sensitive information have been passed
over
well by the sounds of it it's just
embarrassing uh so it sounds like quite
a clever fake call that ben wallace got
it was it was a you know
a very good hacker who managed to do
this he called up ben wallace pretending
to be the prime minister of ukraine uh
someone who ben wallace hasn't met
apparently it looked like him it sounded
like him and at first ben wallace
believed it was him he talked for sort
of eight or nine minutes he says um but
then the questions begun became more and
more ridiculous he started asking uh
specific questions about british
security and ben wallace smelled a rat
and hung up so it sounds as though he
said he played it pretty straight all
the way through doesn't sound like
sensitive information was leaked it then
emerged that pretty patel was also a
victim of one of these hoaxes uh not
quite so much detail on how long the
conversation was she said she didn't
want to give them the time of day by
even discussing it so that just hasn't
really made the news at all um it looks
at the moment like it's just
embarrassing but if if russian hackers
are capable of of doing this then
you know our ministers are going to have
to be
a lot more have to keep their guard up a
lot more than they are at the moment and
it is a worrying development that it's
happening at all well yeah and a
reminder that the offensive is not going
on just on the ground i guess um let's
move on to the other issue that's picked
up by a lot of the papers on their front
pages and that is the the sacking of
piano workers 800 of them kevin uh
you've picked out the metro's front page
first of all they talk about mutiny on
piano ferries by
the shocked workers who found out via
video call that they were to be made
redundant with immediate effect
yeah i mean it's a pretty remarkable
story i mean what a way to treat uh
human beings basically you know telling
them via zoom i mean it's the most
cowardly way possible no no warning no
no notice given they were just told
after a brief preamble that uh the
contracts would be terminated straight
away it was the last day of appointment
with piano ferries and understandably uh
these workers have responded with fury
uh they barricaded themselves uh into
the boats basically 800 of them refusing
to to to leave
the boats um and i mean even more
incredibly uh pinot ferries had a higher
security
uh personnel to go on board people who
were trained to use handcuffs to go on
and get the workers off the boats i mean
i talked about adding insult to injury i
mean it's quite an astonishing way to
treat anyone understandably there's been
political
fury the government have said uh you
know this is unacceptable it's no way to
to treat workers um
but right now it's difficult to see
actually what the government can
actually do about it and so there's a
bit of a standoff now between dubai who
own piano ferries and the unions
representing the workers um and it's
absolutely remarkable story and olivia
makes the front of the telegraph as well
shakes shut down shuts down piano in
battle with union i mean the company
themselves say the move was absolutely
necessary for its survival they say that
it's the only way they can keep their
business viable
um yes but i mean it does feel as though
the government has turned a blind eye
for for too long of foreign-owned
companies just not treating workers uh
properly um i think also we haven't
mentioned how how sort of strategically
important piano ferries is it's
obviously a disaster awful for the
people who have been sacked but it's
also very bad for britain we can't
really afford at this stage for our
ports to be in massive trouble and piano
doesn't just carry holiday makers it
also carried up to i think it was 15 of
um of cargo freight comes in through
piano ferries uh at least that was
before the pandemic so it's it's bad
news if piano ferris is in massive
trouble and you know with with
commodities the price commodities going
way up price of
basket food getting more and more
expensive we just can't afford to have
have chaos at the ports now as well well
yes questions over freight and
passengers as well of course services
suspended for for a week to 10 days i
think lots on that subject that we can
talk about and revisit at 11 and thank
you both for the moment but i will see
you again during the 11 o'clock hour
where we'll talk about some of the other
stories of the day as well